while the national political fight over
voting rights is escalating after the
supreme court upheld two regulations in
the battleground state of arizona
in a six to three decision the court
ruled the voting laws were not
discriminatory
and did not violate the voting rights
act jan crawford covers the supreme
court jan good morning to you what does
this mean
for future cases well good morning erika
i mean you know
this case was seen really as an
important test for these new
restrictions we're seeing on voting and
this conservative court is signaling it
is not likely to
overturn a lot of these new voting laws
that are now being passed in states
across the country the two arizona
voting provisions had been on the books
for years
the first discards ballots cast in the
wrong precinct
the second bans so-called ballot
harvesting where third parties other
than family collect
piles of absentee ballots and turn them
in arizona attorney general mark
ranovich argued the case in favor of the
voting laws
why did you defend this we want to make
sure that everyone has the ability and
the right to exercise the franchise
but we also want to make sure that
everyone has confidence in the process
and they respect the results and that's
what these laws are designed to do
six justices on the court agreed that
neither provision violated the voting
rights act
because they were not enacted with a
racially discriminatory purpose
and states have an entirely legitimate
interest in the prevention of fraud
but the court's three liberal justices
said the decision
undermines the voting rights act because
laws like arizona's discriminate against
minority voters
in a statement president biden said he
was deeply disappointed
it is critical that we make
a distinction between
voter suppression and suspension
the decision comes as 48 state
legislatures have introduced 389 bills
this year alone that could restrict
voting access
cbs news election law contributor david
becker
the need for some kind of basic
standards
of election practices and voting rights
is
very very stark right now and we're
really congress is our last hope really
for a lot of this
now this decision of course came on the
last day of the court's term but
next term the court is going to tackle
some of the most divisive issues in
society
including abortion gail oh boy we'll all
be watching thank you jan